c'est la saint-valentin aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé bon alors
pour la saint valentin ou alors pour ma
lune mais première saint valentin je
voulais assurez vous qu'ils avaient en
fait un pierrot pas et après on fait un
câlin à ferrer en fait j'avais treize
était très angoissée les débats une
petite panne comme son avis très jeunes
bien sûr mais surtout qu on vous connaît
et donc est donc j'ai appelé mon père
laval huppert et areeba dit il m'a dit
mais il m'a dit met du tabasco met du
tabasco et moi je crois que savoir qu en
fait je pensais qu'il y met en fait il
voulait que le bois fin je bosse
parfaite de moi je vais me ça démarre
bien ce timide j'ai passé j'ai pas
passer une très bonne saint valentin
j'avais maintenant mieux du sexe on
l'appelle le piment d'espelette
[Rires]
magali verdict avec nous ça va magalie
vaé vous savez europe et a surgi bout
pas quoi tuning alors moi j'ai fait le
menton ouais une infection c'est ici les
pommettes et cernes c'était le botox et
les dents ah ouais quand même
ouais ouais saviez pas du tout le même
visage avant quoi arrête non pas les
eaux se calment ouais
mais vous êtes tous petits entre les
deux est ridicule est vraiment le
tabouret trop bas mais tout à l'heure
allez merci allez-vous aujourd'hui chez
le maire remercie d'être là bas c'est un
plaisir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous pour la
saint valentin moi j'ai une technique un
peu lâche j'avoue c'est parce que je
pars du principe je veux faire détester
qu'on n'en fait jamais assez pour la
saint valentin
quoique vous fassiez il ya un tel un
copain qui a fait mieux que ce que toi
et que c'était un facteur rien non moi
je parle maintenant je fais enfin je
simule je simulais acheta une gastro
autres comme ça que je passe sa journée
au lit vous nous demandez je vous
réponds j'espère que vous allez faire
quoi pour la saint valentin avec votre
amoureux se soit il fait ce time merci
est ce qui vous est déjà arrivé un peu
fou pour la saint valentin
non non jamais un resto un resto tout
simplement voilà géraldine maillet moi
je déteste la saint valentin
alors moi je vais alors je vais en
bibliothèque
d'abord j'aime pas ça parce que je
trouve qu'il ya un truc force est prévu
l avance ça doit être absolument jour j
et je trouve que c'est complètement que
ce gène est justement dans l'amour ce
qui est bien c'est la magie c'est la
surprise
voilà on n'est pas obligé c'est une
sorte de passage à l'acte obligé bien
sûr j'ai déjà je déteste
après j'avais eu un fiancé quand j'étais
mannequin à tokyo non c'est tout
[Rires]
moi je fais la même la même anecdote moi
c'est moi j'étais au bout d'un merci à
cergy pontoise
oui alors faire dessiner pour yohji
yamamoto
voilà ce à quoi tu te faisais un défilé
pour oliva et j'avais donc un mannequin
japonais qui était fou amoureux de moi
qui ça plairait watanabe et et moi on me
l'avait offert le plus beau cadeau qu'on
puisse faire au japon je crois un
spectacle de sumo non à jeanne de laval
sont des divinités c'est mieux que ma
paie ou neymar et donc il m'avait offert
ça et voilà les produits avait rien ça
c'est génial
vous étiez c'était votre amoureux ouais
c'était à l'époque c'était a longtemps
doivent sortir vous êtes c'était votre
mec en face à pleurer ouais ah ouais
mais c'est vraiment là vous plaît comme
prénom j'adore je vais écrire à y bat
bien sûr je connais les régies vers des
mois c'est ma journée j'adore cette
journée je fais des petits rites et
faire quoi soir avec fatous l'invitent à
dîner dans un restaurant japonais n'en
avait créés donc j'ai voilà je vais
chercher le lait croissants le matin
j'avais prévenu mon bouquet j'adore
cette journée et il ya deux ans j'ai
pavé de roses tout l'appartement
non ça vous avez mis des doigts et leur
pas tout est rentré que c'est que ce
bordel mais moi ces merdes away
non mais c'est ma journée j'adore cette
journée à ben c'est pas du tout
commercial c'est la journée de l'amour
bien sûr et isabelle isabelle chéri moi
j'aime pas la saint valentin mais mon
mari adore la règle d'or les traditions
on a fait avec nôtre meuf
alors quoi l'a fait hier ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui départir dans cette année
dans un restaurant on a discuté au
milieu du repas où il me racontait tout
ce qui faisait jeudi ben là risquant la
déclaration est alors et bah non c'est
pas son truc les déclarations toi qui
m'animait je t'aime encore plus qu'il ya
40 ans donc ce truc ce terrain
mais bon allez rentrer à la maison et me
dit bon on y va quoi pas là qu'on voit
là et je lui dit amr à temps il faut que
ce soit quelqu'un vers tel nom il m'a
dit c'est pas grave mon médecin à
l'hospice l'histoire démarré bien
accuser les jessica biel anne l'humour
ouais ouais bah là ça mon soir la saint
valentin pour moi c'est la journée de
l'espoir la journée de l'amour c'est à
magique pour moi que depuis des années
je dors gagner chez moi un dîner avec
des amis et des amis célibataires
évidemment sauf que d'année en année une
indice case donc l'année prochaine je le
fais tout seul
[Rires]
abou ba moi j'ai toujours de l'espoir
moi j'adore la saint valentin c'est la
saint valentin qui m'aiment pas convié
votre comprend et la dernière fois que
j'ai été vraiment en couple c'était une
très belle histoire j'avais reçu un
bouquet de fleurs chez moi le jour de la
saint-valentin j'ai cru que mon mec vous
voulez me demander en mariage est en
fait il m'a appelée une heure après il
m'a dit je t'envoie des fleurs parce que
tu as vraiment été génial pendant trois
ans mais c'est fini ah ouais ouais
dieu n'a pas voulu à continuer d'aimer
la fête merci oui mais non mais faut pas
faux pas faut pas tourner le dos fait au
moins une année a pas que je trouvais
pas d eux
j'en étais devenu tonnes bah je suis
resté quand même fan de patin donc ne
vous inquiétez pas vous souvenir de
saint valentin moi je fais partie des
mecs qui disent ouais j'attends pas
assez une fête commerciale j'attends pas
sur la sof qui aura cette année je fais
rien non plus et là j'avais offert un
autre et rêvez vous à l'époque j'étais
cariste et j'avais offert un collier à
2000 francs est en france donc je monte
celle à celle affichée à sa place à
l'alsace et je vais pour lui offrir en
fait et je vais donc dos et juste quand
je veux apporter ma vie en fait nous
deux c'est fini non juste le collier en
fait de samantha je vais pas me faire
payer le tour d'un certain je suis barré
2000 francs
quant à donner aux écoliers se demander
qu'est-ce que j'en voyais avait donné
cogner chez l'habitant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors que jamais fêté la saint valentin
on sait pas mais une seule fois je suis
parti à punta cana parce que je
remplaçais le mec d'une copine qui
venait de laurier qu'ils avaient prévu
d'aller pour sa vente à punta cana et
vous êtes tous les soirs on avait des
roses sur les drives amoureuse mais
c'est bon tu sais si tu me lis et massa
le saint-quentin déchiré oui quel style
de valentin vous vous êtes plutôt
romantique ou plutôt expéditif
tu as vu ma gueule